dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on I say here cat
stands for computer aided design
basically a digital 3d model of a scene
here is an incredibly difficult problem
what if we give the computer a
photograph of a living room and the
output would be a digital fully modelled
3d scene a CAD model this is a
remarkably difficult problem just think
about it the algorithm would have to
have an understanding of perspective
illumination occlusion and geometry and
with that in mind have a look at these
incredible results
now this clearly sounds impossible not
so long ago we talked about a neural
network based technique that tried to
achieve something similar and it was
remarkable but the output was a low
resolution voxel array which is kind of
like an approximate model built by
children from a few large LEGO pieces
the link to this work is available in
the video description but clearly we can
do better so how could this be possible
well the most important observation is
that if we take a photograph of a room
there is a high chance that the
furniture within are not custom-built
but mostly commercially available pieces
so who said that we have to build these
models from scratch let's look into a
database that contains the geometry for
publicly available furniture pieces and
find which ones are seen in the image so
here's what we do given a large amount
of training samples neural networks are
adept at recognizing the objects on a
photograph that would be step number one
after the identification the algorithm
knows where the object is now we are
interested in what it looks like and how
it is aligned and then we start to look
up public furniture databases for
objects that are F similar to the one
presented in the photo as possible
finally we put everything in its
appropriate place and create a new
digital image with a light simulation
program this is an iterative algorithm
which means that it starts out with a
coarse initial guess that is being
refined many
many times until some sort of
convergence is reached convergence means
that no matter how hard we try
only minor improvements can be made to
this solution then we can stop and hear
the dissimilarity between the photograph
and the digitally rendered image was
subject to minimization this entire
process of creating the 3d geometry of
the scene takes around five minutes and
this technique can also estimate the
layout of the room from this one
photograph now this algorithm is
absolutely amazing but of course the
limitations are also to be candidly
discussed while some failure cases arise
from misjudging the alignment of the
objects the technique is generally quite
robust non cubic room shapes are also
likely to introduce issues such as the
omission or miss placement of an object
also kitchens and bathrooms are not yet
supported note that this is not the only
paper solving this problem and made sure
to link some more related papers in the
video description for your enjoyment if
you have found this interesting make
sure to subscribe and stay tuned for
more two minute papers episodes thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time
[Music]